welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is adria Lawrence an assistant professor
of political science and a research
fellow at the Macmillan Center at Yale
University professor Lawrence is a
scholar of the Middle East with
particular expertise in North African
politics she studies conflict and
collective action investigating how
people come to mobilize in favor of
ideologies such as ethnicity nationalism
religion and democracy today we'll talk
with Professor Lawrence about her new
manuscript Imperial rule and the
politics of nationalism welcome
professor Lawrence thank you very much
let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it
my book investigates a question that has
often been taken for granted by those
who look at the collapse of the European
empires and that is the the wave of
nationalism that swept the colonized
world basically in the wake of World War
two okay and what questions do you
address in the book the book addresses
why it is that national mobilization
occurred and why there was so much
variation in when and where it occurred
so most of the time scholars have tended
to take Nationals mobilization for
granted given the unpopularity of Empire
the creation of the United Nations a lot
of events that be legitimized Empire in
the mid 20th century many scholars see
nationalism as something that we can
really take for granted it's kind of an
obvious response to colonial rule by the
mid 20th century and when I look at
nationalism I saw that there are a lot
of surprising things about it that it
didn't happen everywhere at the same
time it didn't all of a sudden spring up
after World War two some places never
had nationalist movements some places
had nationalist movements but got them
relatively late in some place in places
nationalisms happened relatively earlier
in addition nationalism wasn't the only
way that colonized populations opposed
colonial rule they asked for other
things as well they engaged in strikes
they engaged in other kinds of protests
so I began the project by noting that
there was a lot of variation in the way
that populations responded to Konya rule
and trying to explain some of that I
think most of the time scholars have
seen nationalism not as something that
needs to be explained but as something
that could explain something else so a
lot of people have considered
nationalism to be one of the factors
that caused the collapse of the European
empires but haven't specifically taken
nationalist movements themselves as the
object of study and so that's what I try
to do in the book manuscript ok and
let's define nationalism what do you
mean when you want to use that term well
following on scholars like Ernest
Gellner I basically use what I think is
a pretty standard definition of
nationalism mainly that the the desire
of a people for self-rule so in the
colonial context that means movements in
which people were asking for
independence
they wanted or if they were asking for
autonomy in other words they wanted to
rule themselves as a nation and they
made claims on behalf of that nation so
I think to be nationalists whenever
people say that they are - listen when
they when they're asking for
independence or autonomy ok and what
drove you to write the book what was
your inspiration
well actually the inspiration came from
a class I took here at Yale as a
visiting student while I was doing my
graduate studies at the University of
Chicago I spent a semester here and I
took a class with the William Foltz who
is one of our Africanist and has written
a terrific book on Africa and while I
was taking his class I became surprised
at how little nationalism there seemed
to be in sub-saharan Africa having
studied North Africa Morocco and Algeria
I had always taken for granted and
nationalist mobilization and the
resonance of nationalism to colonize
populations because those are places
that we see as strongholds of
nationalism where nationalism was
particularly strong and I began to
wonder then well why was it so different
in Sennett
let's say or in the Ivory Coast why was
it that nationalism seemed to come so
late to Africa and not at all and and
that's how I got started thinking about
the question and how did you do your
methodology how did you do the research
for the book so I decided to focus on
the French Empire for a couple of
reasons one of which is that the French
Empire is that was the second largest
empire in the mid 20th century but it
hasn't been studied quite as much in the
English literature as the British Empire
the French Empire also allowed me to
control for differences between empires
so a lot of studies of decolonization
compare the the British Empire to the
Belgian Empire to the Portuguese to the
French and then they end up sort of
comparing across those five units what I
decided to do was to hold the imperial
power constant and look within the
French Empire and try to explain why did
some French colonies get nationalist
movements earlier than others why did
some French colonies not ever get
nationalist movements while others did
and I spent some time collecting data in
French archives and I also used the
secondary that are sure on the French
Empire the second component of the
project was to look closely at one case
and for me that was the case of colonial
Morocco and so I also spent some time in
Morocco
interviewing those who had participated
in the Nationals movement and when you
were doing the research were there any
particular surprises did you have any
difficulties actually I did have some
difficulties and there were some
surprises I had started off thinking
that what I was going to do was build a
dataset of nationalist activities in the
French Empire or in Morocco and I would
have an original quantitative data set
and to do that what I started doing was
looking through records of events that
have happened in Morocco and I couldn't
decide what should count as nationalist
I would be looking at a description
written you know in the French police
reports that said that there was a
strike and a bunch of workers were angry
because they felt that they were being
denied a certain wage level that the
French workers enjoyed or there would be
a riot on
arm by Moroccans who said that they
weren't getting adequate water to
irrigate their lands and so this had all
been categorized as nationalist activity
but I wondered you know is that really
nationalism I mean they're not really
talking about the nation they're asking
for a higher wage or they're asking for
a for more water you know why should we
think of that as nationalists and I came
to realize that most people think of
anything that the natives in the
colonies were doing as nationalism if
they were agitating at all and I started
to think you know maybe we shouldn't be
calling all of these things
nationalism maybe we should make some
distinctions among what people were
asking for it so I was surprised to see
that there was so much variety in what
it was that colonized populations were
were asking for and more demanding and
let's talk about your findings why were
some countries nationalists and others
did not follow in that same path well I
essentially make two arguments to
explain this the first address is
exactly that question why did some
places turn nationalist well other
places actually never got nationalist
movements so a very minority of the
French Empire including places like
Martinique and Guadeloupe Rey Union
these places have not had that much
nationalist activity so why was that the
first argument I make looks at some of
these alternative demands that people
made that weren't Nationals demands and
I noted that in the French Empire before
people asked for independence or
autonomy they tended to ask for reforms
to colonial rule so what they asked in
the French Empire was for France to make
good on its promises of carrying out a
civilizing mission and of assimilating
those populations so across Africa in
places like Martinique Guadeloupe even
in places like Algeria colonized
populations said fine you know you said
you're going to incorporate and
assimilate us then do it make us all
French citizens and I argue that where
they became French citizens they there
was no nationalist movement or there was
very limited nationalist activity so
political equality as it turns out was
important for
for stalling demands for independence or
autonomy and this only happened in a
small number of places so it's hard to
see because for most of the Empire the
French did not extend citizenship rights
but they did do it in some of the
smaller island places like Martinique
and and Guadeloupe they also did it in
Senegal but only for four cities in
Senegal they gave some of them political
equality while they denied it to the
rest so there we have an opportunity to
see within one country whether those who
get political equality either use it as
a platform to become nationalists or
whether they actually experience
political equality is something good
that they that they're happy to have and
what happened in Senegal those who got
political equality in the towns of that
car Rufus and Gauri they moved more in
the direction of incorporation with
France so they asked for greater rights
they tried to extend those citizenship
rights across Senegal they did not move
it in nationalist direction and they
didn't do so until very late in the
period until after the French had
actually rescinded those citizenship
rights and what do you conclude in your
book so I conclude that political
equality was an alternative way to end
Empire it was an alternative to granting
independence the second conclusion I
make is that it concerns a timing of
Nationals mobilization and I argue that
nationalist activity typically got
underway after Frances Authority was
disrupted in each particular colony so
this argument well the first explains
why some people would have wanted to
either be nationalists or not
nationalists the second explains when
could they organize nationalist activity
and in the French Empire particularly
during world war ii french rule was
disrupted in some places because other
powers invaded so in north africa the
french forces landed there in 1942 we
see nationalist activity beginning after
the invasion of the Allies similar in
Vietnam after the French forces they are
destroyed by the incoming Japanese Ho
Chi Minh organizes an ash
movement this argument suggests that
disruptions in imperial powers authority
preceded nationalist mobilization and
helps provide an opportunity for it to
happen but a lot of people have seen it
in reverse that that Nationals
mobilization disrupted Imperial
Authority and not the other way around
very interesting thank you so much for
being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you very much a pleasure
for more information about Professor
Lawrence and her work please visit our
website at yale.edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale